what I'm gonna quickly do is break apart
one of the questions I think it's like
6c or something like that and then I'm
gonna I should pick a pens back up in a
different space and I'm going to show
you what's going on with this why this
limit actually ends up being important
it is neither the pure nor the applied
problems that we're really looking at
today that other point of this exercise
okay so first one just this guy here one
of the reasons why questions often get
given in particular ways is to see if
people will make a very common mistake
because you know they're like oh I know
this technique and I know this limit
right so I can use it all the time and
it's a handy thing right whenever I see
a theory on a sine theta I know what to
do with that now this is a limit with a
very simple answer okay but it's got
this is giving given in multiple choice
questions before and I know like the
distractor that people are thinking of
is oh I know what to do with this
theater on theta square non-science
squared write this like this part's
gonna be one and then they're gonna say
ah it's 1 over 1 - wait hold on a second
and then there is some trouble they
break apart that denominator which you
can't do and then they're nuts in
trouble right we forget that with limits
we can do all the things that normal
limits do the reason why we usually do
algebraic tomfoolery to rearrange things
is because you can't simply evaluate the
denominator you get a 0 in the
denominator
that's a big problem right but once you
have a look at this guy right sine theta
as theta approaches 0 we know that sine
theta also approaches zero but that
doesn't make the denominator 0 does it
right so in this case I'm just looking
for a simple evaluation of and by that
this is actually what you would write
don't just go straight to the answer I'd
say that tops going to be 0 I evaluate
that and this is one take away the 0
that comes from that sine squared this
line is actually really important it
doesn't look like it's much because all
zeros and ones but it shows that I
understand what this limit means and
that I can just evaluate it and that's
why it's simply equal to zero okay so
don't be fooled by ones that look more
complicated than they really are
sometimes you can just use a trig
identity to expand stuff out and cancel
it everything's nice ok pick up your pen
again and if you're still like big
questions or something like that go
somewhere else find like a new column or
a new page or whatever because this is
the real point now I'm not going to
prove this entire result for you I'm
just going to get up to the point at
which this result we've proved ends up
being like aha
this is why we spent so much effort
drawing diagrams that
that when we first learned how to
differentiate things when we first
learnt calculus we didn't know how to do
anything so we just said calculus is all
about gradient it's all about the
gradient function and the graining is
just rise over run rise over run in the
particular case where run is like well
when the run is zero right and that's
why we had to bring in limits and all
that kind of thing so when you look at
something like this again we're going to
go back to first principles now remember
by first principles can you quote it to
me at this point right after - is going
to be equal to I'll start you off
there's a limit that's the pot every one
forgets and then what happens after that
what am i getting on the top I've got a
fraction right and on the top I'm going
to get come on tell me f of X plus h
thank you very much minus f of X and
then what's on our denominator H very
good and this is just the rise over run
that we get from the gradient function
right now in this case and this is a
part we're going to need to work
together in this case my f is just sine
so this is what I get the limit as H
approaches 0 of sine of X plus h that's
just my f of X plus h minus what minus
sign and then on the denominator it's
still just my just my H there's nothing
there ok now what do we do with this
well what's the only thing at your stage
of knowledge that you can do to try and
simplify this have a look there's not
much you can do here you can't do much
with the denominator you can't do much
with this guy what do you do with this
you just give me the expansion for this
right ok come on right along with me
again write the limit what is the
expansion for sine of X plus h this is
still there kicking around your brain
where you off for me it starts with a
sign right sign of what sine X
cause H very good see it is still there
and what's the other part of the
expansion yeah you can do sine H cos x
we tend to write them in order of angle
so I'm just going to not that it matters
but I'm just going to write in order of
X and then H because that's the order I
did before so there's the expansion take
away sine X and that's all divided by H
what a mess okay now in order to work
with this thing
I want that a whole lot of these have
X's in them and remember as we've seen
before when you have things which are
independent of a limit this is an H
limit right all these X things are kind
of irrelevant to the limit right sine X
doesn't care what H is sine X is still
say X so what I want to do is seek to
write this in such a way that I can pull
out those X parts and then just leave
the limit in terms of all the H's right
so what can I do here hmm well I notice
in my three terms two of them have a
sine X and the other one has a cos x
right so I'm going to try and group them
together a little bit so I'm gonna do a
big fat bracket here I've got sine X cos
H minus sine X I've just paired up my
brought together my sine terms that's
all over H and then I also have this
other guy over here with Shaz cos x
instead good morning never seen a maths
teacher before school obviously okay cos
x and then there's a sine H over H you
starting to get suspicious at this point
is it is it clicking yet now I've got a
sum of limits the sum of limits is the
limit so I start again I've got the
limit of a sum the limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits so I'm gonna break
this apart into two and whilst I do that
I'm also going to factorize out all
those X terms
they're completely irrelevant through
the limit so in this case here I'm going
to factor out the sine X gonna bring out
the front then I've got the limit and
what's remaining in that limit after I
factorize out what if I got on that
numerator cos cos H right cos H take
away what
I factorize that so I've just got one
there that's all divided by H so it's a
Miss eh so there's my first limit and
then I've got this guy over here cuz X I
factorize him out because he's
irrelevant to the limit of here comes
the limit now what's left inside the
limit something that should look really
familiar to you right it's just sine H
over H now I'm just going to hit pause
right there
a number of you will already actually
know what you're supposed to get at the
bottom okay that's actually really
important to me because therefore you
should know what happens with all of
this we're not quite other words yet
this parts going to be equal to of
course what if we just spent proving
this part one so you'll get this guy
right cos x multiplied by one now if you
know where this final answer should go
therefore you know that this whole piece
here should equal it should equal zero
now like I said we're not quite out of
the woods yet this guy here I invite you
to have a little think about it's it's
own little sort of problem but the main
problem was this guy which we have just
proved how you can deal with okay and
then once you open the door to that once
you know the derivative of sine cos is
just the complement of that ten is just
the ratio of those and then you get
everything in this entire universe of
tens and second Kosek and all that kind
of thing for fun okay